Marvel actors are carefully scrutinized
before being selected by the studio and
have to sign some of the strictest
contracts in Hollywood from excessive
secrecy to exhausting press conferences
let's look at the outrageous roles
actors have to follow in order to join
the Marvel Cinematic Universe Marvel's
control over their cast begins on the
screen despite the success of Fox's edgy
Deadpool films Disney is adamant about
keeping their Marvel movies appropriate
for a wider audience since Disney wants
to appeal to kids as well as adults in
these big-budget superhero films they
have been particularly careful to tone
down any violence another role is
providing good examples for children
smoking for example is prohibited in any
of the Disney films one of Nick Fury's
most iconic attributes from the comics
his gigantic cigar was nixed by Disney
in Samuel Jackson's portrayal of the
grizzled veteran spy even though Disney
is careful to aim their Marvel films are
wider audiences they have presented
plenty of tv-ma rated content through
Marvel Netflix shows such as daredevil
and the Punisher even when actors step
off of a Marvel set they're expected to
adhere to the Disney image in addition
to generally avoiding controversy this
can include visiting children's
hospitals and similar acts of
philanthropy Scarlett Johansson has
worked with charitable organizations
such as USA Harvest an Oxfam which feed
people from impoverished third-world
countries she joined Mark Ruffalo in the
natives of Standing Rock during their
protests against the Dakota access
pipeline and even donates it to Navajo
made solar trailers to provide shelter
heat and power to the protesters during
the winter months Robert Downey jr. is
no stranger to philanthropic donations
and hospital visits but his most
heartwarming act of charity to date was
more personalized for the collective
project and in character as Tony Stark
he delivered an Iron Man inspired bionic
arm to a young Avengers fan for mother
partially developed right arm in order
to become an Avenger MCU actors are
required to complete demanding daily
workouts and maintain a strict diet
specially formulated to mold them into a
superhero physique most Marvel actors
log around two hours of gym time a day
and keep a diet consisting mainly of
boiled chicken and dried oats these
requirements are taken very seriously
and actors are given warnings that they
miss even a single workout you know I'm
a naturally competitive person you know
and
honestly I just wanted to achieve the
look that I really needed to get for her
manga chris hemsworth worked hard to
transform into one of the most
physically imposing avengers eating
every three hours and sticking to old
school trainings such as pull-ups rows
and squats Robert Downey jr. engaged in
weightlifting or training for his
transformation into Tony Stark but found
Wing Chun to be useful for building tone
and endurance half the stuff that I've
been able to do right in my creative
life are principles that I learned on
the mat with my Sifu Chris Evans started
with weight lifting to bulk up and then
began incorporating plyometrics and
gymnastic exercises into his workouts
for agility Evans told fitness and power
how intense these workouts got I was
puking at the gym they were brutal
absolutely brutal a little bit of bicep
tolerance Tom Holland routinely practice
gymnastics and boxing but he also used a
machine that relies on electronic muscle
stimulation to improve muscle tone after
joining the MCU actors have come to
terms of the fact that they have
absolutely no say in character choices
or development Marvel has shown
throughout the Avengers franchise that
many of these characters will be brought
together as different stories intersect
this means that each actor is a small
cog in a much larger machine and has to
follow the guidance of directors who
know more about how the story evolves
than they do for big stars who are used
to getting their way this can be a very
jarring experience Edward Norton who
portrayed Bruce Banner in 2008 see
Incredible Hulk
was rumored to have been replaced over
creative differences after the Oscar
nominee met with studio President Kevin
Feige and director Joss Whedon about
bringing Bruce Banner to the first
Avengers film Marvel released a
statement the statement said northen is
not going to return due to the need for
an actor who embodies the creativity and
collaborative spirit of our other
talented cast members whatever dispute
Norton had with Whedon and Feige clearly
could not be resolved so Mark Ruffalo
was cast as a new Bruce Banner soon
after spoilers not only ruin a movie but
knowing how it all goes down might
prevent a film goer from buying a ticket
so Marvel subjects that stars to
rigorous procedures in order to avoid
plot leaks even actors just under
consideration for roles in the MCU
must enjoy extreme secrecy to get a look
at Marvel scripts
Elizabeth Olsen disclosed some of these
practices at the Seattle AC e comic-con
revealing that in order to even read a
full script actors had to turn in their
cell phones before entering specially
designed rooms these script reading
rooms were windowless and actors were
only permitted to enter alone they've
also given only one chance to go into
these rooms so they had to finish the
script in one sitting so we couldn't
like take our time at home or anything
like that they wouldn't give us a hard
copy so I just got my pages and even my
pages had a fake ending Olsen revealed
at the convention that none of the
actors had any inkling of the infinity
war plot until they were all piled into
a van and given the full rundown many
actors realize that they have been given
fake script details after they began
filming as Marvel have placed various
changes in each script so they could
determine the origin of any potential
leaks there were scenes in there that I
have I thought we were shooting that
nobody ever shot in fact Tom Holland
didn't even find out he was going to be
turned into dust until moments before
filming his demise although reshoots are
commonplace on most sets they're taken
especially seriously by Marvel reshoots
in the MCU are prevalent due to the
complexities that emerge as several
different story lines intersect such as
when heroes like I am Man and Captain
America come together for blockbusters
like The Avengers films in order to
maintain continuity across the franchise
reshoots are often needed as the
overarching plot evolves as a part of
their contract all MCU actors are
obligated to show up for reshoots
regardless of what project they might
currently be working on here giselle
Bichette lightful his own struggles have
reshoots for Thor the dark world during
an interview at The Telegraph in which
he recalled saying this is torture man I
don't want to do this but Elvis agents
insisted reminding him that it was part
of the deal he agreed to Albers
frustrations came from the fact that he
had been called back for Thor reshoots
while filming for mandela long walk to
freedom after getting into the headspace
for such a serious role gluing on some
fake hair to return to Asgard as home
Dahl was apparently quite jarring for
the actor although some actors prefer to
do their own stunts
Jassi contractually prohibits MCU actors
from performing any stunts that have
been deemed too hazardous by the
higher-ups
actors must adhere to these rules
because they are practically
irreplaceable to Marvel during filming
and any serious injuries could severely
hinder the
production process this also allows
Marvel to save money that would
otherwise go to covering costly
insurance for the actors some actors
such as Chris Evans and Chris Hemsworth
have found ways around this rule and
managed to push the limits and the types
of stunts they could lawfully perform
that's a younger and more recent
addition to the Avengers team Tom
Holland has also discussed his
experiences with doing his own stunts
for spider-man homecoming at the New
York Film Festival premiere of the lost
city of Z Holland stated I did as many
of the stunts as I could but there are
some things legally that I couldn't do
even there was some rapport that these
actors are stepping up to the plate to
do as many stunts as they are able to
Marvel is careful to leave the most
dangerous stunts to the professionals
this way they can ensure that no harm
comes to their stars many of whom might
play important roles and several
different upcoming films instead of
signing up for a single movie or series
at a time Marvel actors must initially
sign a contract that outlines exactly
how many films they will appear in as a
main character however unlike most
contracts this agreement also includes a
clause that requires actors to appear in
any other MCU movie while the contract
is still active this means a studio can
choose to include a character in any
Marvel film they once without actors
having the option to decline these
appearances for example if an actor has
signed on for four films then they are
required to make any appearances that
Marvel once until the standing contract
expires with the completion of
production on the final film and the
contracts even if this appearance is
just a 5 second cameo in a different
superhero film such as Captain America's
appearance and spider-man homecoming MCU
actors are contractually obligated to
show up another stringent rule that MCU
actors have to follow is participating
in all promotional press tours and act
as a touch meant to any given Marvel
movie is far from over once the cameras
stopped rolling not long after they take
off their costumes they begin packing
for a traveling caravan of interviews
these tours are extensive and can leave
actors exhausted and jet-lagged
rather than focus on a single city or
even country the press tours are held
all over the world to garner maximum
exposure for the upcoming film MCU
actors could find themselves in China
One Nights and Europe the next
struggling to plaster a smile on their
faces to spite sleep deprivation I'm
sorry I really don't know what are we
doing
right bye sometimes if emotion begins
before production is even done and
actors may be required to attend major
conventions between shooting hours not
only are all MCU actors at the beck and
call of marvel for cameos or press tours
they must also be available to all
Disney toy and video game manufacturers
whether this means appearing at stores
across the country to promote the latest
Marvel products or stepping in front of
a green screen to capture facial
features for the newest Avengers game
actors are contractually obligated to
meet the needs of merchandise Asst
actors working with Marvel must come to
term to the fact that they have
basically sold their likenesses to
Disney vendors although it may be a
little unsettling for actors to hold
tiny versions of themselves and they
pick up an action figure this is a
non-negotiable part of the deal they
agree to when joining the MCU it is no
surprise that Disney takes franchise
merchandising so seriously considering
the Marvel consumer products bring in
even more revenue than the film's though
to put this in the perspective in 2011
Disney's consumer products division
produced an income six hundred and
eighteen million dollars higher than the
movies released by its film studio one
of the most steadfast rules that actors
must follow once they become a part of
the MCU is not appearing in any DC
extended universe movies as Chris
Hemsworth revealed at the Australian
2017 supernova comic-con it is actually
illegal for any Marvel actors to act in
a DC movie once part of the Marvel team
actors are not allowed to cross
contaminate the two separate universes
by accepting a role as a DC character as
Marvel and DC are direct competitors and
engaged in a staunch corporate rivalry
on the same scale of Starbucks vs Dunkin
this non-compete clause makes perfect
sense
Marvel carefully select stars who they
believe will earn the millions in box
office sales and merchandising so it's
natural that they would do everything
they can to stop these painstakingly
chosen actors from bringing the same
huge income to their competition the
agreement seems beneficial for both
comic entertainment industry Kings are
summing actors crossed over from one
universe to the other could muddy the
waters for fans of both Marvel and DC
since Marvel movies are generally pretty
mild and don't contain graphic violence
nudity or egregious profanity they can
appeal to a broad audience
controversial actors may limit that
crucial mainstream appeal so Marvel
would really prefer it if off screen its
actors behaved as if they rose up star
as Captain America Tom von NOLA
portrayed Emily Moore in Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame soon
after being cast he revealed that Marvel
vetted him before signing him up and
apparently the studio has done the same
to others the actors said on second
captain's on Ireland's rté raidió one
Marvel filmmakers in the US didn't know
me so when I went over there they were
meeting me for the first time they do
background checks to make sure you're
not a white supremacist and they're not
hiring someone with weird baggage check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the Bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]